foreign
that we now want to explore in the
course of the next um 30 to 40 minutes
let's start on the North Atlantic side
so to speak by asking about America and
specifically whether we need a strong
America to keep western or Western
derived ideas of humanitarian assistance
of democracy alive or is this in fact a
false premise in the first place I
suppose one of the things that people
might say is that if America is not
going to provide those particular values
hypocritical and flawed there may be
many they may be in many other cases
none of the other major actors in World
politics is going to provide them either
not China not Russia not anyone else but
let's see what our speakers think Esky
do we need that America flawed as it is
still in the game
so um
so you're asking do we need a strong
America for the Western uh humanitarian
and democratic ideals my I have a
problem with this question because I
would like to question the signifier
Western and what do we mean by strengths
so uh when we say a western for
humanitarian democratic ideals
most such ideals
do have a much more diverse pedigree
than uh previously thought you know most
of these ideals took their political
form during the Enlightenment period and
Enlightenment
was a global tide rather than being
confined to the so-called West if we
were to substitute pluralists for the
word Western which I agree is a very
problematic word in many ways the idea
thinking about Afghanistan and Ukraine
and one of the things that they have
somewhere in common is that having
emerged as polities that had a much
longer history that didn't necessarily
include say pluralist multi-party
Politics the idea of civil society the
idea of having a media whose job it was
to be dissenting and critical of those
in authority and that some recognizable
aspects of all of that could be seen in
Afghanistan over the last 20 years and
in Ukraine over the last 30 years since
um the end of the Soviet Union if that's
the premise could I throw that back to
you and say that that is what America is
being posited as potentially still
necessary to maintain
but the problem is that is not the
premise well it depends whose premise it
is
that we think that America who's we
I mean apparently
the the common sense think that we a
strong leadership a western leadership a
superpower it should police uh you know
a show with strength in place in in to
you know build democracies deter bullies
but also this gives that superpower the
quote-unquote legitimacy to uh wage Wars
in Far Away lands that is a weakness
rather than a strength
that is in that sense is not I mean when
you say when you change Western with
pluralistic it it doesn't change uh the
common uh Paradigm that is my problem is
it a fatal flaw in other words you're
saying that the Americans exists okay
it's a fatal flaw it is a fatal flock so
shabnam can I turn that to you the Fatal
flaw that in esgu's conception has been
identified there is that America's
arrogation of itself to the right
moral superiority absolutely this means
that actually the idea of America as an
actor that can bring some kind of
pluralism liberalism if you want to use
that word to places and crises that
exist far outside of North America
simply can't be held up for any kind of
a praise
no I don't agree with that I think when
we think about Afghanistan where post
2001
there was no infrastructure no hospital
no roads no education people were living
tribally it is a very tribal
misogynistic cultural traditional
Society
we need actors like the US
to support Nations like Afghanistan and
introduce humanitarian and Democratic
Values the people of Afghanistan have
always wanted to live equally freely
represented by a fair government where
they can help hold them to account and
we didn't have that and although the
last 20 years was far from perfect of
course corruption
was there was widespread there were many
difficulties but you can't expect 20
years for a country to become
self-sufficient and independent so I
back to the question I think whether the
time is over for the U.S and we need to
see whether there's a a global Coalition
or whether there's a new actor in the
scene that's another question but there
needs to be countries who have the
capabilities the privilege need to step
in when needed so we'll have in the case
of Afghanistan absolutely
there was a period about a decade in
between the late 70s to the late 80s
when another modernizing power of the
Soviet Union essentially invaded
Afghanistan and brought a modernizing
infrastructure there which was secular
which brought women's education but of
course which was run by an authoritarian
society would you grant any validity to
the modernization that was brought
during that decade
no because that was that was different
and I think it's one of the reasons why
we you know we're opposing uh Russia
against the sort of the intervention and
in Ukraine I think the Soviet Union had
many flaws and it's it's the reason for
its collapsed in Afghanistan which like
I said historically is a very very
religious Society
Soviet Union occupation did not work
there I think any intervention needs to
acknowledge like Stefan mentioned you've
got to acknowledge the division within
the society it's it's a multicultural
multi-ethnic country and one of the the
difficulties we had in the last 20 years
in implementing a just democratic system
was that we overlooked the geography the
culture the dynamic the demographic
Afghanistan has always been up until
1973 in monarchy it's never had
institutions and governance structures
for the last 44 years that it's a bit
that has been in war so in a lot of
these systems need to be built within I
don't think the the Soviet Union model
worked but I do believe that the the
last 20 years with all the flaws that it
had the model did work people lived
freely I traveled to Afghanistan back
and forth probably every year or every
other year I saw how first people were
for freedom and for equality we brought
about change and I'm not saying it was
perfect any sort of intervention will
come with with difficulties you've got
to really understand who you're there to
help what the community stands for but
but intervention matters and it did
matter to the people of Afghanistan so
with all the flaws shabbir the United
States in this model would still be the
only superpower that has enough of that
commitment to the idea of a pluralist
liberal Multicultural identity in some
form to maintain that kind of system and
without America that simply wouldn't
exist would you agree no absolutely not
and I think firstly if we can clarify
when we're talking about intervention
we're talking about the United States
and its allies dropping over 300 000
bombs on Afghanistan over the space of
20 years that is an average of 40 bombs
a day for 20 years straight
um so you know it's it's all fair to
talk about intervention as a means of
nation building we are to talking about
the destruction of an entire country and
I think when we're talking about Western
values and pluralism I think we should
remind ourselves about what that
actually means and in the last 20 years
we've seen the West illegally invade and
occupy countries we've seen the West use
Mass aerial bombardment against
civilians we've seen the West use
chemical weapons in Iraq like white
phosphorus and depleted uranium we've
seen the West armed dictators like in
Saudi Arabia to crush pro-democracy
movements in Bahrain to destroy Yemen
we're talking about a country countries
in the west where our own leaders are
passing legislation now to limit our
ability to protest to give the state and
the police more powers to spy on us to
infiltrate our organizations to stop us
from dissenting these are the liberal
values that we're talking about so I
don't think the U.S has any kind of
moral Authority here because you'll be
doing these things quick come back from
shopping up can I I just say when we
talk about interventions and whether
it's humanitarian Democratic or a
liberal values can we please not compare
Afghanistan to some of the other
countries you've mentioned Afghanistan
is a very different country it has been
it like I already described earlier when
you talk about intervention we need to
consider
the the specific nation that we are
intervening in and Afghanistan needed
intervention it needed it needed 300 000
bombs drops in it what's happening he
needed Trump's mother of all bombs but
what's happening in Afghanistan with the
Taliban killing people to a side of
Texas
we're supposed to remove who are now
stronger than they were put a hold for a
second we're going to get some more
voices then bring it in but there's
gonna be plenty more to debate Stefan
please well you look I think an
important distinction has to be made you
know it's like I definitely would be
very strongly supportive of of the idea
of of liberal values liberal orders and
there is some values there definitely in
it but of course where the problem lies
is that in often when we do
interventions and I've seen it working
inside governance while governments as
well this becomes just the narrative and
unfortunately not an uh the narrative
rather than actually the real true
driver it's when it becomes
geopolitically driven you get an offload
of this collateral damage that is
actually not taken so my point would
actually be there are certain bits in in
these societies and definitely and in
the early notice in Afghanistan you know
there was a case for trying to do
something the point that we have to be
very careful with with all these
interventions is that are we risking
making it far worse than or making it
better there is a tendency to assume
that the interventions will make it
better and that we actually can
establish these kind of things it's
evident well I'm afraid that actually in
Afghanistan we undermine actually the
emergence of a stable State because we
we made actually those actors that were
in charge of the state
um it it was an increasingly more
corrupt country it was increasingly more
run by by actually financial means often
Aid fueling it at some point it becomes
unsustainable so so we made a lot of
Errors By being in a hurry by thinking
oh quick fixes can be doing it and
actually by the time of the fall of
Kabul it wasn't sustainable anymore it
was already for years clear that
actually that wasn't the way to do so
it's a lot to do with the way we do it
rather than maybe the principle that
there are values that are worth
defending can I bring ezy back yes um I
I understand shebnam's point of view
about education infrastructure but this
uh this is pure colonialism I mean when
you look at
Egypt under uh Britain British rule I
mean when you look at Algeria when you
look at Tunisia uh when you look at
Morocco when they left there was a
intact Administration I mean but they
changed the whole
um society and the whole establishment
in their colonial mindset and we we now
see the post-colonial calamities going
still on today I mean I I understand
that Afghanistan is different but there
are something some things that we should
understand when we think United States
when we think United States as a you
know a humanitarian Democratic you you
know there are there are 18 uh human
rights treaties International treaties
and U.S is only party to five
and ratifying an international treaty
requires two-thirds of the Senate and
which means that it will not change
anytime soon and what what and coming up
on Stefan's point I think the whole
point of these interventions and
democracy promotion is based on the
transition Paradigm which were led by
American policy advisors and this
Paradigm goes like this
there comes the collapse the collapse of
the authoritarian regime taken by an
external actor or people like what we
have seen in the post-arab uprising then
the the Paradigm assumes a rapid
democratization starts with a new
government through national elections
and then a promulgation of a new
Constitution and hence the Democratic
institution did a whole generation of
democracy Aid Community were led by this
transition and only a few examples are
shown to work this is not working so
let's take that point and use it to move
on to something that is now of great
relevance in the Here and Now moving on
from that to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV